shortly after you and your brother were  born  your father and I divorced and we each  took one son obviously ha ha ha I got  second pick I have a twin brother  brother  [Music]  maybe you disco parties al-arian  so how are things career-wise ha ha  great do what he most wanted village  just get away you're fired  those are great crushing it I brought  you here to continue the family business  the only venue blood and broken boobs  and I left that life behind me  I understand hmm I wonder what this does  [Music]  holy-moly become a villain Mogambo  what did you guys do today there's  always the blind guy  nothing  so Mike  Oh what about that sport Wow Oh Carlton  here  I'm a concern to appreciate me  differently gave me we've been waiting a  long time  it was so fluffy I thought I was gonna  die me on the Thomas support you know  you two are villains now ah  I mean hello speedy hope you can on the  gimmick please  [Music]  you